San Francisco will become the first US
city to ban e-cigarettes sales after a
unanimous vote by its Board of
Supervisors just yesterday the mayor has
indicated she plans to sign the measure
the most popular east cigarette brand
that's Joule is based in San Francisco
and they said this quote this full
prohibition will drive former adult
smokers who successfully switched the
vapor products back to deadly cigarettes
deny the opportunity to switch for
current adult smokers and create a
thriving black market instead of
addressing the actual causes of
underaged access and use e-cigarettes
have not been approved by the FDA the
agency has called a cigarette use by
young people a quote epidemic their word
we contacted the FDA about the band but
have not heard back CBS News medical
contributor dr. Tara Narula
and CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman
are here you are exactly the people to
talk to about this because you can talk
about should they do this and you can
talk about can they do this so on the on
the subject of can 21 year old and up if
you're in San Francisco you can buy
alcohol you can buy marijuana you can
buy regular cigarettes but now maybe you
can't buy e cigarettes can they do that
yes they can unless and until it's
challenged but there's no point in even
trying to get a creative challenge about
taking away property without due process
because in California the state has
something called ballot initiatives or
propositions which we know is
referendums so jewel is already prepared
to get the signatures to get on the
November ballot to absolutely get rid of
this ordinance and so jewel may carry
the day because adults particularly
adults in places like California or San
Francisco don't like being told by
legislators what they can and cannot do
in their own private time and after all
they're adults Tara what can you tell us
about the health risk because some
people are concerned that this is a
gateway to smoking real cigarettes but
can you is it known what the health risk
is about e-cigarettes this is a big
unknown and nobody was prepared for how
prevalent this is particularly in the
youth market and
we're really all playing catch-up at
this point and the problem is we don't
have the benefit of research we don't
have the benefit of time so nobody can
tell you after two or three hundred
puffs of an e-cigarette over 20 years
what is the potential risk nobody can
say that what do we know right now we
know that nicotine is particularly
damaging to the adolescent brain it's
very addictive it can affect memory and
concentration we know that nicotine can
have cardiovascular side effects raising
blood pressure and heart rate and that
the e-cigarettes themselves what's
inside it has been shown now to
potentially damage the blood vessels
we've seen seizures and people who have
used it we've seen accidental ingestion
x' explosions we know that some of the
flavorings can have respiratory effects
and cause lung disease and lung problems
and we've even now had studies that show
it can damage DNA and we know there are
carcinogens or cancer-causing agents in
some of these solvents but at the same
time in San Francisco it's legal to
smoke cigarettes well it's it's even
more peculiar than that it is legal to
smoke cigarettes it's still going to be
legal in California and in San Francisco
to be able to vape marijuana right and
you can use marijuana and of course
there's alcohol so the argument you can
understand of what the possible downside
here is is what always happens you're
going to have the health risks that Tara
mentioned you're gonna have adults who
are going to if this stays in force in
effect who are going to say well look
you know I was smoking e-cigarettes and
I got off of cigarettes now I'm gonna go
back to cigarettes but also as always
happens a flourishing black market but
but is there evidence that e-cigarettes
help you quit smoking there's not so
there have been studies that say yes
there have been studies that say no
there have been studies that say people
end up with dual-use they're using
e-cigarettes and cigarettes but as of
now there's no conclusive scientific
evidence that it's safe and effective
for quitting smoking is not approved for
that indication so the recommendation is
to use things that are approved
counseling and also the seven approved
by the FDA medications but all the
organizations including the American
Heart Association are saying we do need
more research to look into this idea
could it help smokers there's more being
done
not as much as it should no but if you
are an adult smoker and you have a
choice between continuing with a regular
cigarette or going to an e-cigarette
what would the doctor recommend you know
and patients have asked me this in my
office and I think right now because
it's not approved because we don't know
the long-term risks you know the safer
options are things like nicotine gum
nicotine patch other medications that
would be my recommendation now and the
hope is if we have the research in the
future I would love to compassion it's
an alternative but there's still a lot
of big questions around this well my
parents were both heavy smokers and they
both died very early so I'm thinking how
about just not doing it
yeah how about that all right thank you
very much Tara and Rikki but I know it's
it's much I know it's harder than that I
get that too